is
[Music]
this year with records
unfortunately ladies are telling me abc
news is the white house that will make
sure
that every american lives abc news
washington so without further ado uh
i want to be introducing a person that i
cannot believe she's so brave to be
without that code if you talk about that
if you talk about
in these days that we talk about a
strong man
let me introduce you a strong woman
speaker pelosi
[Applause]
thank you very much jose not only
for your wonderful introduction which
i'm sure my grandsons homeless will
appreciate
but for being such a source of charity
to so many people
whether it was whether it's a government
shutdown and people didn't
have jobs and were not being paid
you fed the people when it was whether
it was hurricanes
earthquakes whatever happens fires you
are there
to feed the people you are a source of
great
charity charity and that's so
why it's such an honor to be with you
today so let's start with the three
most important the virtues faith hope
and charity suzanne firstenberg
and her husband doug and their children
have faith
they believe that the arts will send
a message to make the change that is
necessary
they believe that this
impression will inspire people will make
them
sad but also make them strong to say
what can we do to stop this i've known
doug and suzanne
for over 30 years i remember when their
children were born so it was a personal
privilege for me to be here with them
today and to see
this remarkable demonstration of the
arts
i always believe that the arts can bring
us together
whatever our differences because we cry
together
we mourn together we're inspired
together
and that faith if you didn't have
faith that it could make change you
wouldn't be doing this
so thank you for your deep faith
and that faith is in the goodness of
others
and the faith and the goodness of people
who is like
jose andres but as i said earlier a
source
of great charity a source of great
charity
it's such an honor that he is here and
my understanding is
that some people want to make
contributions and that you are well you
probably will announce that
it will be to feed the hungry a biblical
call to feed the hungry
that chef andres honors all the time
so we have faith in the goodness of
others
that gives us hope that is our mayor
she is such a fabulous leader
she sees it all in perspective
she sees it all in perspective she leads
with strength with charity
with faith and she therefore gives us
hope
the mayor has had one of the biggest
challenges
because so many things have been
happening
around this and everything that goes
with it without going into any detail
there but i have seen her
in in action and
is fills me with emotion to see
her standing with john lewis when he
made his last appearance
in washington d.c on his way home to
atlanta to go on his
way home to heaven with the mayor at
black lives matter plaza
that on that occasion but it said so
much
the visual it said so much about all
that people have been through
with the hope that we have for the
future
so suzanne and doug and suzanne
especially to you
the artist i know people are going to be
coming to write names on these
flags as well of loved ones that they
have lost
it's almost incomprehensible that here
in america
this would happen but thank you for
vision giving us
this optic this visual manifestation of
it
not only the lives how horrible
have all these like the families
the families the communities that have
lost maybe a thousand
health care providers health care
providers they risked their lives to
save lives
and now here they are here they are in
this display
so thank you suzanne for giving us this
opportunity how appropriate
at rfk because rfk devoted his life
to faith hope and charity so i'm honored
to be here with all of you
i'm honored to be with my grandson and
my daughter
uh so that they could see they could
see what you made a decision to do
and all that that is involved involving
your family
to plant these flags and mayor it's
wonderful that it will be here
until the end of november so that many
more people
can see this thank you all very much let
us always pray
thank you
thank you so much madam speaker we'll
now have um
have you plant a flag and jose andres as
well
just to make a note um people have asked
if we could if they could contribute to
this cause the greatest contribution
is to contribute to jose andres
wonderful efforts
because we've got to keep everyone safe
and fed
throughout this long winter that
approaches thank you
[Music]
[Music]
still down
don't walk in front of the camera dude
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dude seriously
good luck tomorrow
right here right here one second
if they're coming back to the car
because otherwise they're
my understanding is they're coming back
for some questions
her questions
okay
[Music]
are coming back for questions